Vsauce Kevin here and we're making each
other insane we're in an era of constant
Mass delusions and the toothpaste of
delusion does not go back in the tube
Mass psychogenic illness is an annual
event at one school in Nepal where every
single year students shout and cry
uncontrollably nothing causes this
grandmas in Kansas ironed their mail to
kill Anthrax and this guy drank silver
till he turned blue and it's all because
of the madness of crowds people are the
worst and a lot of people together are
the absolute worst except that
intellectually diverse crowds are also
way way smarter than individuals they
have more accurate judgments they find
cures for diseases faster they often
have a better sense of what people want
a lot better than even a carefully
selected group of the top Minds in a
field it's why William F Buckley said
he'd rather be governed by the first 2
000 names in the phone book than the
faculty of Harvard I've often been
quoted as saying I would rather be
governed by the first 2 000 people in
the Boston telephone directory then by
the 2000 people on The Faculty of
Harvard University figuring out how to
get the best Stout of people without
getting the worst out of people is a
seriously delicate science and when it
goes wrong you start swallowing
tapeworms to fit into a prom dress
this bull is named cat blue and he's a
monster most rodeo bulls are about 1 500
pounds or 700 kilograms Cat Ballou
weighs nearly a ton if everyone watching
this video got together in a stadium and
workshopped a guest at cat ballou's
exact weight we'd be harnessing the
power of crowds to get a really bad
answer the more we talk to each other
the worse our Collective guess would be
but if we all guest from home separately
and had no idea what anyone else had
guessed the average of our estimates
would probably be right on the money Sir
Francis Galton tallied 787 guesses at
the weight of an ox and the crowd was
off by a single pound how many jelly
beans are in the jar
foreign
the wisdom of crowds is really complex
but The Madness of crowds is not complex
group crazy is super easy paracelsus ran
the ultimate con partly because he
didn't think it was a con he was
mystified by magnets because they're
pretty mystifying imagine being a German
peasant in 1528 the leeches aren't
curing the rash on your butt you see a
well-known genius use a magnet to
magically attract metals to find all the
common sense physics you've ever seen
with your own eyes then he tells you
that the same magnet can pull diseases
right out of your body why wouldn't you
believe him paracelsus convinced people
that magnets could transfer sickness out
of the body and into seeds and when they
were planted in the Earth the patient's
disease would then go away as the seeds
grew
this sounds insane to us but it made a
lot of sense back then the delusion of
magnetism as a healing agent spread
throughout Europe a few cases of magnets
healing what turned out to be
psychosomatic illness and a whole lot of
fantastic stories no one could ever
verify and just like that you get a
centuries-long mass delusion that paved
the way for Mesmer to mesmerize
science is amazing but it's ripe for
Mass delusions because we can almost
never see any of it sometimes real
sickness makes crowds delusional like
the possible ergot poisoning that fueled
the Salem witch trials
sometimes we just make it up
my body is like a garbage bag full of
jello draped over a skeleton it turns
out that 12 years of sitting at my desk
making YouTube videos with no physical
activity was a bad choice
serendipitously the world's best
personal trainer app asked to sponsor
vsauce2 and I said yeah that's probably
a good idea co-pilot connects you with
your own Expert Fitness and health coach
to personally tailor a routine to you
your needs your Fitness level whether
you go to a gym have a home gym or have
no equipment at all after taking their
short quiz I matched with Mike and told
him I don't have a gym membership but I
do have a five pound kettlebell he
developed a three day 30 minute workout
program for me to start with that I'm
already feeling the results of a few
weeks in but having a social connection
knowing there's a real person monitoring
and talking to me about my progress
right now is the difference between
taking care of my body and ignoring it
and despite knowing for years that I've
needed to do this I just always assumed
I'd get to it later and later crept
closer and closer to never but I'm
actually doing it now because of the
ongoing real connection with a real
person that co-pilot provides it's been
the difference for me and could be for
you too so click my co-pilot link to get
a free trial with your own Expert
Fitness and health coach and thanks to
them for sponsoring vsauce2 getting me
in shape finally
so the annual hysteria at that school in
Nepal is an example of social contagion
being driven by strong relationships and
close ties it's like electricity the
closer to conductors the shorter the
leap the 1962 June bug outbreak in a
South Carolina dress making factory
caused nausea and rashes the workers
blamed it on being bitten by bugs in a
tainted shipment of textiles which makes
a lot of sense that's part of the
problem the more plausible it is the
more social contagion spreads Paul
Garrison believed ingesting way too much
colloidal silver was beneficial because
it can be effective topically to treat
wounds and even prevent conjunctivitis
in newborn babies centuries of
homeopathic anecdotes and pseudoscience
turned him into basically a Smurf that's
called Algeria by the way argentum is
the Latin word for silver which is why
its chemical symbol is a g textile bugs
right textile bugs so entomologists
surveyed that South Carolina dressmaking
Factory and they found nothing except
for extremely stressed workers which is
fertile territory for social contagion
and the conditions were there for an
informational Cascade just like with
dust bowl farmers in the Great
Depression who refused to adopt drought
resistance hybrid Seed corn that was
significantly better researchers from
Iowa State found that it was because
there was an informational domino effect
among friends and family they just
didn't trust experts and salesmen the
dress Factory workers believed their
friends stories about the bug bites and
their illnesses fell like dominoes but
it's always everyone else who's crazy
and and ill-informed right wrong
it's you but it's not your fault
herd mentality obviously developed as a
survival Instinct packs are better than
trying to be a rogue social
relationships are a huge component to
feeling happiness and well-being and you
know from my invention of friends video
that the dunbar's number heuristic means
were probably cognitively adapted to
only interact with a few hundred people
not Millions at once on Twitter or
YouTube but uh please like And subscribe
Thomas Friedman proclaimed that the
world is now flat and he's right your
world not the Earth your social group
can be a wildly dispersed improved choke
shotgun blast of people you don't even
really know and won't ever meet so how
do you take advantage of all the amazing
parts of crowds without succumbing to
social contagion or even Mass psychotic
illness we used to think it wasn't even
possible in 1841's extraordinary popular
delusions and The Madness of crowds
Charles McKay wrote man it has been well
said think in herds they go mad in herds
while they only recover their senses
slowly and one by one and that's true 54
years later Gustav labong commented on
groups from juries to democracies
concluding that in crowds it is
stupidity and not mother wit that is
accumulated crowds breed Madness and
stupidity that is absolutely accurate
and absolute nonsense James sirwiki's
the wisdom of crowds laid out the
requirements to harness crowds rather
than be victims of them we need diverse
opinions that are independent of the
opinions of the people around them
that's why talking about cat balu's
weight actually makes our guesses worse
and being siled turns us into a
collective expert we need to be
ourselves sir Wiki describes this as
decentralization and make use of what we
know individually then we need a way to
take all those individual judgments and
compile them into Collective wisdom
all that's the easy part the hard part
and sometimes the impossible part is
trusting the group to be fair it's a
tightrope that's getting harder and
harder to navigate as we're influenced
by everyone else's personal
death-defying high wire act between
group Madness and group wisdom
you're probably in some really great
communities who are fun and
inspirational and really positive for
you maybe it's at work or school or the
World of Warcraft horde Guild you've
been in since you were 12. and you're
probably part of some crowds that make
your life worse and
maybe they're even making you sick
so
are you part of the wisdom of the crowd
or are you part of the madness
probably both
and as always thanks for watching thanks
again to co-pilot for sponsoring this
video and motivating me to get my
Fitness on track click the link in the
description to get your own free trial
now